الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذتهمت
وكاله الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه روسيا
بقصف محطه زفالوجيا النوويه وقالت الوكاله
ان اثنتي عشره ضربه على الاقل سجلت في
موقع المحطه وان روسيا تعرض العالم باسره
للخطر
في المقابله اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
القوات الاوكرانيه بانها شنت قصفا
المدفعيه على محطه سفر روسيا نوويه مما
تسبب في اضرار بالمحطه وخطوط نقل الكهرباء
اليها واتهم المتحدث باسم الوزاره
اوكرانيا بما سماها استفزازاته هدفها
احداث كارثه نوويه
مبروك مبروك
عن الاستفزازات الهادفه لخلق تحديد بوقوع
كارثه في محطه
النوويه خلال اليوم الماضي اطلقت مدفعيه
القوات الاوكرانيه 11 قذيفه مدفعيه من
العيار الثقيل على المحطه كما قصفتها
مرتين اليوم في فتره الصباح تم اطلاقه
اثنتي عشر قذيفه مدفعيه انفجرت حول وحدات
الطاقه بعد ذلك اطلقت قديفتان اصابتا خط
الكهرباء الذي يغذي المحطه قواتنا ردت
بتدمير موقع اطلاق نيران العدو في مستوطنه
مارجانيز لمقاطعه دين بروستد الوضع
الاشعاعي في المحطه ما زال طبيعيه سيتم
توضيحه عواقب الاضرار الناجمه عن القسم
بعد فحص المحطه من قبل خبراء وكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه ومؤسسه روستهم
ان قصف محطه زفروجيناويه غير مقبول وان
التصعيد يجب ان يتوقف على الفور وجدد
غروسي دعوته اطراف النزاع لانشاء منطقه
امام حول المحطه
بسيط جدا لا تقصف في المحطه النوويه هناك
ولا تنفذ عمليات قصف منها